los avances hechos durante los 20 años
de guerra contra el talibán han sido
deshechos en tres meses de ofensiva
insurgente esta es una señal de la mala
estrategia de eeuu o de la debilidad del
ejército afgano
pero yo creo que es un poco uno en el
otro vale decir que claramente
sorpresivo que con la inteligencia que
los eeuu tienen con su gente sobre el
terreno para durante 20 años no se
preparó mejor la salida de las tropas de
los eeuu de afganistán de la embajada de
los civiles de los órganos que
colaboraron con los eeuu y además
demuestra también como del otro lado el
gobierno afgano no ha tomado
suficientemente en serio su papel en una
verdaderamente digamos colaborado con
los eeuu que han gastado trillones de
dólares en equipamiento entrenamiento de
300 mil soldados y policías y además con
equipamiento de todo tipo para
prepararse para resistir a una posible
invasión de los talibán así que es un
poco digamos un fracaso de la
inteligencia de los eeuu
de la política de en este momento y de
la de la actuación del gobierno afgano
hasta ahora
como veníamos diciendo el presidente
afgano del país qué mensaje le da este
hecho a la población a ghana que tiene
que quedarse porque no tiene otra opción
bueno claramente significa estoy
abandonando el país estoy abandonando
ustedes a su suerte es un mensaje muy
negativo que naturalmente le da mucho
aliento a los talibán que entraron hoy
en afganistán se dice que ya entraron en
el palacio presidencial así que es
claramente
prácticamente a aceptar la derrota
pensar solamente en sí mismo en no ser
un líder que está ahí con su gente
intentando de afirmar los acuerdos de
doha así que en una ya digamos
sufrimiento a necesario por los civiles
precisamente mencionaba ustedes los
acuerdos de doha tienen futuro ahora
y yo creo que todo esto ya está en el
pasado los talibanes están ocupando que
están son más fuertes de cuando dejaron
organizaron hace 20 años y yo creo que
era un período muy difícil porque
claramente
afganistán está en el centro digamos
desde asia central tiene 6 países
alrededor entre ellos china irán irak y
otros y podemos bien pensar cómo se
transformará en nuestro cable